hey youtubers is Charlie thank you so
much for so many questions for my
Walking Dead Q&A today I know a lot of
you had questions about Netflix
availability in other countries you will
have to check with your local streaming
services just because it's different in
every country like Netflix in the UK is
very different from Netflix in the
United States everyone should have a
pretty okay time finding a way to watch
it before the season five premiere so we
should all be good and thank you for
your bonus video suggestions - I think
like a Michonne slice-and-dice videos
what's gonna be next but if you have
absolutely no idea of what I'm talking
about my name is Charlie I'm gonna be
doing a whole bunch of Walking Dead
videos this season so be sure to
subscribe to everything I have a link to
my schedule for the fall for all the
videos in the description so just a
general spoiler warning for everything
through season 4 as we start doing
questions all the season 5 questions
that I answer our pure speculation so
technically I don't consider them
spoilery but you know mild spoiler
warning ok so here we go question number
1 Nik naks asks was Seth Williams
character already introduced who is he
and what's his connection to Rick's
group yes they introduced him at
comic-con as father Gabriel from the
comics he's playing a comic book
character but that doesn't necessarily
mean he'll be exactly like the father
Gabriel in the comics you guys totally
know the drill with that you know the
show changes things all the time from
the comics of all the new characters
that are coming in season 5 he's like
one of the two that I'm really excited
to see I'm a big fan of Seth Gilliam and
based on the types of characters he's
been playing more recently like on Teen
Wolf I'm interested to see how he
handles spirituality inside The Walking
Dead universe his Teen Wolf character is
like this soft-spoken mystical healer so
of course they're gonna make him the
spiritual guy on Walking Dead even if
they didn't make him a man of God he
priced he'll come off as the spiritual
one
the other big character that I'm really
interested to see though is that
crazy-looking policewoman that's been
harassing Beth in the trailer right now
I'm thinking of her as Lady negan but
that's not who she is like they didn't
genderbent negan in terms of connection
to Rick's group I feel like Seth
Gilliam's character is gonna be totally
different from his comic book version so
I don't wanna make too many predictions
about him I know there was a lot of
speculation about him possibly being the
one that took Beth but based on what
we've seen in the trailers I don't think
that's the case on to question number 2
Cameron Cicero's how do you think
they'll give significant screen time to
each character this season there was one
point in the trailer when there were
over a dozen on screen at the same time
so the short answer is is that not
everyone is gonna get you know good
screen time they'll basically focus on
like three four five main characters and
then just hit everyone in the group
scenes if you remember the solo episodes
from season four I don't think that are
gonna do a lot of those I think that as
the group moves around though the camera
is just naturally gonna focus on three
or four specific people more than others
Beth is like the one exception to that
because her story is taking place in
this other different area that that
creepy Hospital it seems like she's
gonna be there for at least the first
half of the season so she's definitely
gonna be getting a lot more screen time
that she has in the past but question
number three Netta de Toro asks I'll
never understand why it's okay to have
zombies with exploding heads but they
can't drop f-bombs yeah this is like a
weird standards and practices thing
networks have those people who tell
showrunners what it's okay to leave in
the standards and practices people are
trying to help the networks not get
fined by the FCC that's just in the
United States each country is just a
little bit different so if they think
the FCC is gonna complain about a
certain word or a certain level of
violence or sex the last the showrunner
to remove it there is absolutely no
logic to it standards change from year
to year all the time sometimes it'll get
more strict as time goes on the DVD is
the exception to that AMC can slap a
warning label on it and then just leave
everything in it's the same deal with
the way movies get rid in the United
States
it's totally messed up and it kind of
sucks but question number four gab
Borgia asks do you think that spoilers
hand will be cut off in season five I
just omitted the name because most
people don't know who that person is no
I don't think that's gonna happen
mostly for sake of practicality but I
think that someone on set was playing a
prank one day for people that don't know
there's a major character in the comics
that loses a hand but the show just
hasn't done it yet
so recently Norman Reedus tweeted a
picture of a chopped off hand with a
ring on it and everyone went crazy but I
think happened is Norman Reedus was just
having fun
on set one day they chopped like a
random characters hand off and he was
just having a little bit of fun with the
audience I think they're gonna do that
scene as a wink to the comic book fans
but it's not gonna be a main character I
know a lot of you are asking you know
why wouldn't they do that if it was in
the comics you know why not do it mostly
for sake of practicality just because it
takes a lot of time to get an actor in
prosthetics and then a lot of money to
digitally support it with digital
effects
it just makes filming with that
character as time
way more expensive and even though
walking dad does make a crap ton of
money it's like the most profitable show
on cable right now next to Big Bang
Theory it's also one of the most
expensive shows to produce for example
AMC spends more money producing Walking
Dead than HBO spends producing Game of
Thrones I think the numbers I heard last
year were that it costs about four
million dollars to make an episode of
Walking Dead and it made about twelve
million dollars in like ad sales and all
the various stuff so at the end of the
day it still made eight million dollars
but question number five Darci Peterson
asks during the governor's attack on the
prison do you think that he would have
really let the survivors leave the
prison unharmed if they chose to give it
up I actually I don't think the governor
knew completely what he was gonna do
until he just started talking into that
megaphone I think he'd really only
thought through his plan up to the point
of the megaphone and the threats and
then something inside him just snapped
while Rick was trying to reason with him
had Rick and the survivors chosen to
leave on their own free will I still
think the governor would have found a
reason to go after them I also think
that prison would have totally turned
into another Woodbury situation so
either way the governor would have ended
up going crazy again
and killing a bunch of people I just
like the way they implied you know when
they give us that governor story-arc
that there was no way he was gonna be
able to leave that lifestyle behind but
question number six jgq Joe asks
everyone has been talking about Daryl's
character maybe being gay do you think
that he is is there something going on
between him and Carol yeah I saw some of
the news about this I'm not really sure
why people thought that he might be gay
maybe just because he hasn't had sex
with a lot of women I have to say that
it is okay for you know a character to
not have sex with every woman that
passes his field of vision if you ever
watched arrow Stephen Amell said that he
actually talked to the writers because
Oliver Queen the Green Arrow character
basically was having sex with every
woman that came on the show that he was
not related to and it became like a big
problem it was really funny that's the
weird thing about TV either there's like
too much sex or not enough sex there's
never like the right amount of sex but
think about it this way Daryl has never
really struck me as being a ladies man I
don't think he's gay I think he's just
got this undiagnosed personality
disorder that causes him to recoil a
little from the thought of intimacy and
just to clarify I don't think that he's
a sexual that's basically like the
absence of sexual thoughts during normal
circumstances but the zombie apocalypse
the opposite of normal right now where
the character is he's just starting to
think of the survivors as his real
family like he and Rick just
acknowledged each other's brothers in
the season 4 finale that's how long it's
taken I think what we'll see this season
is him just opening up to people a
little bit more if that continues then
of course the natural progression would
be for him to develop a more intimate
relationship if the opportunity
presented itself I know there is some
peril Darrell shipping out there and I
do see it a little bit in some of the
subtext but I don't feel like the show
is gonna do any of that I think both
those characters really care about each
other but I don't think they think of
each other as like sexual partners well
we might end up seeing in like a future
season if Daryl continues to develop his
personality it's just open up and have a
sexual relationship with like a guest
character or something like that there
has been some official word though from
Scott Gimple and crew he they basically
said at no time during season 5 are they
gonna address Daryl's sexuality which I
think was a funny way to respond to all
the is Daryl gay questions but it's just
something that they don't find
interesting to talk about so they're not
going to spend any of their time writing
episodes dealing with that so the short
answer is is that Daryl's brain is just
too fried to deal with relationships or
the idea of being intimate with someone
right now but on to question number 7
Kieran McFadden asks do you think
they'll kill off a main character like
Daryl or Glenn well neither one of them
is completely untouchable but I'm pretty
sure like definitely sure they're not
gonna kill Daryl off he's one of the
most popular characters right now and I
don't think they're gonna go into a game
of Thrones territory we're just like
anybody can go at any minute the first
person to go will probably be one of the
more minor main characters obviously
there been a lot Oakland rumors about
him leaving the set saying goodbye to
the cast there have even been like some
Maggie pregnancy rumors I have no way to
confirm any of these so I'll just say
you know I would not be surprised if
they didn't kill anybody in season 5 it
seems like they want to keep the show
going as long as possible and the
easiest way to do that is to just keep
everyone alive I am gonna start laying
bets on Bob going though I feel like
they're gonna give him like a really big
hero moment to prove to himself he's not
terrible and then right away a bunch of
walkers are gonna swarm him so you know
he could die a hero instead of just
being an alcoholic I also think there's
gonna be a few red shirts in the
premiere so keep your eyes peeled for
them they're always the first ones to go
that's why they're called red shirts on
to question number 8 Frasier chard asks
is there any truth to the statement that
Robert
when wants the show to run for 12
seasons so every time I've heard Kirkman
talk about the series you know first he
talks about the comic and he says I'm
gonna keep making it till people stop
buying it which is basically forever and
on the other side of that he does
similar things about the show the
problem is that because TV is so much
more expensive to produce than the comic
eventually the show will become too
expensive for them to keep making that's
what the spin-off show is for a way to
continue the show without having to pay
crazy money for season 20 what happens
is is like as you get on at seasons
actors salaries rise so they would be
paying them like millions and millions
of dollars you know if you wait too
expensive to keep making episodes but on
to question number nine this is actually
a funny one braiders asks are you
sponsored by razor now I keep seeing
that razor headset a lot no that's
totally funny it's just super boring
like this background and I just wanted
some color in it and those are the
headphones that I wear whenever I edit
my videos it would be pretty sweet to
have a sponsorship right now you know
absolutely no one is paying me to do
anything so anytime you see something in
the video that looks weird or I
mentioned something a lot it's just
because that's what's stuck on my brain
at the moment I will say there are a lot
of people like buzzing in my ear about
you know businessí YouTube things if
there's ever like something I think that
you guys would like really enjoy and the
opportunity prevents itself then I might
do like some sort of ad related thing
but that's plan I can happen anytime
soon even PewDiePie doesn't do a lot of
like straight-up ads he does like really
big integrations with humblebundle and
other services like that like giving out
discount codes it's way less invasive
it's like a whole different part of the
platform so I just let other people who
care about that stuff deal with it but
on to question number 10 Drake Henderson
Dumont asks how do you think the TV show
will end and will Rick ever die
it would be funny if he was immortal
like some crazy thing happened and he
just could never die like Captain Jack
what I think is really gonna happen is
they'll just end it in some ambiguous
way where one or a couple of the
characters just keep traveling around
trying to survive they'll try to like
leave it in a way that lets you know
that things will just generally continue
like life will just go on I do
definitely think that a bunch of main
characters will be dead at that point
though I mean it'd be disingenuous if
they all got to live for 12 seasons I
would like to see Beth you know maybe
Carl among the last people standing that
would be like one of the less depressing
endings if you wanted to be super
hardcore
though you'd kill everyone else and let
Rick survive I don't think that he would
want to live if everyone else he cared
about was dead
in fact that's actually kind of what
ended up happening to the governor after
season three so now just a couple really
big reminders bonus videos for Walking
Dead on Sundays now my next one's gonna
be Fermi shown so be sure to subscribe
to get it
I'll also be live-tweeting some of the
episodes when they get here I'm pretty
good about not being spoiler but all the
links for my social stuff are in the
description below and congratulations to
this week's giveaway winner
Alex dredge you and an Amazon gift card
I'll be messaging you on your channel
for details so the next round of the
giveaway will just start whenever I post
that be shown video but right now you
can click here to learn more about the
new characters coming on in season 5 and
you can click here for my top 5 the
badass Rick Grimes moments thank you so
much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives